mais par élise lucet
le président du nouveau centre hervé
morin est l'invité de preuves par 3 bons
soirs soit merci d'être avec nous en
2012 plus que jamais dans toutes les
têtes un nicolas sarkozy dont vous avez
été le ministre de la défense je le
rappelle il ya quelques mois encore
semble de plus en plus en campagne il
défend son bilan
le centre se reconstruit et s'émancipe
que vous allez nous en apporter la
preuve
j'imagine au cours de l'émission qui
s'annonce et il reste suspendu néanmoins
ce centre à la décision ou la non
décision le j'y vais j'y vais pas de
jean louis borloo mais rassurez-vous à
hervé morin je sais que votre vie ne
tourne pas autour de jean louis borloo
vous l'avez dit cette émission non plus
pierre rossi scioli de la sp puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindrons j'aimerais qu'on parle
d'abord de l'exécution d'oussama ben
laden vous avez suivi de très près bien
sûr sa traque lorsque vous étiez
ministre de la défense
avec votre expérience est ce que vous
diriez que les américains nous balade
sur le récit de cette opération de ce
raid qui a amené donc l exécution du
terroriste numéro un
non je crois pas je pense qu'aujourd'hui
contrairement à l'idée généralement
conçu c'est que les affaires militaires
les affaires des armées restent secrètes
la grande muette etc
je pense que tout ça il faut pense qu'il
ya aujourd'hui un tel niveau de
transparence
oui bien sûr il ya quasiment qu'un
secret contraire dans ce qu'on se
raconte
non et donc je pense que vous ne pouvez
pas vous permettre de commencer à me
balader l'opinion publique
internationale en ayant une histoire qui
ne correspond pas à la réalité
les deux oreca a observé que c'est
twitter qui a été le premier à annoncer
la mort d'oussama ben laden
vous avez l'intervention des
hélicoptères vous avez
il ya pendant six mois le feuilleton
wikileaks ou les pages des télégrammes
des plus diplomatiques américains se
retrouvent se sont retrouvés sur le sur
l'espace public donc l'idée moi je
suppose une sorte de crise bien entendu
pas comparable mais au fait où rosso
modo on aurait pu se dire que là aussi
on va essayer de travestir un peu la
réalité d'écrire sa propre histoire
c'est impossible et d'ailleurs 1 c'est
impossible
et deuxièmement le faire serait idiot
parce que comme toute façon un jour ou
l'autre la vérité ce c'est le jour où
vous êtes pris en flagrant délit de
mensonge
là vous avez à rendre compte à l'opinion
publique et pour vous c'est d'une
violence absolue j'observe que c'est pas
toujours le cas quand c'est le sens
inverse
j'ai le souvenir au moment de la mort de
dix soldats en afghanistan où le canard
enchaîné publié en page 3 soit disant un
rapport d'un service de renseignements
avec un fac similé qui émanait qui
expliquait toutes les carences de
l'armée française et ce fac similé en
l'occurrence c'était simplement le blog
d'un sous-officier à la retraite d'une
association
s'il l'avait fallu que les pouvoirs
publics se comporta de cette façon j'ose
imaginer quelle aurait été la réaction
donc ce que je sais pour ce qui concerne
la défense de la base d'arguments sent
bon les états unis et la france ont
toutes les deux des démocraties même si
le contrat social n'est pas le même
c'est que je ne peux pas croire un seul
instant qu'on commence à vous balader
sur les grandes largeurs parce que ça
vous revient en boomerang est ce que
vous êtes favorable la diffusion de la
photo de ben laden avec apparemment donc
de deux balles dans la tête
qu'est ce que ça apporte ce que ça
apporte quelque chose à l'information
que de voir un homme mort on vous a
entendu un instant évoquée la guerre en
afghanistan est ce que votre discours
change aujourd'hui après la mort de ben
laden sur l'intervention des forces
occidentales n'ont pas du tout non
absolument pas c'est pas on n'était pas
la présence de
de centaines de milliers de soldats de
50 pays n'est pas lié à la présence d'al
qaïda aux frontières de l'afghanistan où
au sein de l'aghanistan la présence
d'oussama ben laden pas seulement nous
sommes en afghanistan nous communauté
internationale 50 pays
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
soldats nous sommes là pour essayer de
réinstaurer un état en afghanistan
police et une justice une arme et un
état de droit en tant qu autant que
possible leurs gouvernements leur la
reconstruction d'un pays les à l'accès
des jeunes filles à l'école etc etc
vous n'êtes pas là pour simplement faire
la guerre à des terreaux ici c'est votre
si c'est la seule cause de votre
présence
c'est c'est que vous avez d'ores et déjà
échoué là comme on parle aujourd'hui on
va pas rien d'un débat alors attendez
moi surtout je crois profondément c'est
gelé toujours dit même d'ailleurs
penchée thème usa défense parfois me
vallet certain nombre de haussements de
sourcils c'est que je pense que l'année
disons aller 2012 sont des harnais
charnière pourquoi parce que à la
demande de la france et ensuite des
autres principaux membres de l'alliance
atlantique
nous avons dit il faut qu'il y est un
objectif clair et précis qui soit en
quelque sorte le témoignage à l'opinion
publique
et cet objectif clair et précis c'est
que nous soyons en mesure de pouvoir
transférer un certain nombre de zones
sous responsabilité à gan est de
constater ensuite si les afghans sont
capables de tenir ces zones l'otan a
fixé un plan ce plan amène à un
transfert de zone en 2011
voyons si ça se fait voyez aussi ensuite
les afghans sont capables de tenir dans
l'hypothèse où nous verrions que la
théorie de la tâche d'huile ou
progressivement quelque sorte donne à
l'afghanistan aux autorités afghanes des
zones de responsabilité et on les étend
progressivement si nous voyons que cette
stratégie la réalité pour l'instant on
voit bien le bourbier
bien sûr si nous voyons que cette
stratégie-là échoue je crois qu'un jour
ou l'autre et moi je le dis clairement
il faudra s'interroger et se poser la
question notre présence en agglo manque
alors là s'interroger sur le sacrifice
de 56 ans très bien mais très
honnêtement si vous connais si vous
étiez capable d'écrire l'histoire en
2001 vous m'appelez la libye maintenant
est-ce que nous sommes face à une
situation d'enlisement des forces
occidentales pour vous non je pense
qu'on n'est pas en situation
d'enlisement je pense en revanche qu'il
faut qu'il y est peut-être avec
l'accompagnement de l'union africaine de
l'onu qu'il y est un processus politique
qui s'engage alors pour l'instant il n'y
a pas de dialogue possible
mais je suis pas convaincu que des
frappes aériennes sur plusieurs mois
nous amène à régler à faire partir
kadhafi repartir aida fille pour faire
court voyons là d'accord
un mot sur la syrie enfin qui réprime
durement alors là sans être menacé ce
qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures y'a
moins j'espère qu'il y aura une réaction
de la communauté internationale qui soit
à la hauteur des exactions commises par
le régime de bachar el-assad
en même temps il ya un principe de
réalisme on peut pas dire la communauté
internationale allait face à des
réalités et elle est bien obligé de
faire avec et donc bien entendu il faut
tout faire pour empêcher cela est-ce que
tout d'un coup on peut décider de
s'engager militairement dans chaque pays
qui se révoltent c'est une autre affaire
j'ai encore une question en rapport avec
votre passage au ministère de la défense
hervé morin le député socialiste bernard
cazeneuve qui sort un livre ces jours ci
comme vous d'ailleurs bernard cazeneuve
rapporteur de la mission d'information
sur l'attentât de karachi estime que le
gouvernement auquel vous avez donc
appartenu n'a transmis que des documents
de seconde main en quelque sorte qu'est
ce que vous lui répondez moi c'est faux
ce faux oui vous allez parle d'une
démocratie malade
enfin je connais bien bernard cazeneuve
je comprends très bien qu'il veuille se
faire un coup de pub sur sûr sur cette
histoire
moi j'ai transmis tout ce qui était
transmissibles j'ai même écrit au juge
d'instruction où il s'appelait style
trévidic pour lui dire que j'avais
d'autres documents que ce qu'il me
demandait à partir de cela j'ai gardé
copie du courrier à partir de cela il
m'a fait une demande extrêmement
exhaustive très large
j'ai transmis sa l'ensemble des services
du ministère de la défense qui étaient
susceptibles d'avoir des documents
le ministère de la défense à quoi les
services du ministère ont fait une
recherche a plus approfondie possible
pour sortir tous les documents services
de renseignement compris pour être tout
à fait honnête pour mieux garantir
qu' on ne gardait pas des documents sous
le coude j'ai demandé à chaque patron de
me confirmer par écrit qu'ils avaient
fourni tous les documents qui pourraient
intéresser la faire donc honnêtement
mois soit au moins menti soit ne souhait
pas non mais je dire on peut retrouver
des documents qu'on aura pas retrouvé
parce que honnêtement 90 parfait des
documents qui datent baisse à 15 ans qui
sont dans des rayonnages mais moi j'ai
fait mon travail parce que j'estime que
pour les familles des victimes et à
devoir de vérité
par ailleurs j'ajoute que s'il y a sur
cette affaire des pots de vin ou découle
rétrocommissions ça va pas apparaître
dans des documents militaires alors
nicolas sarkozy je le disais considère
que son bilan est bon dit il le défend
vous avez lu son interview dans
l'express pas l'une cinéma il l'a dvd
finalement son bilan est-ce que vous
aussi vous avez envie de défendre le
bilan de nicolas sarkozy le bilan des
quatre ans non mais je vais pas j'ai pas
devenir complètement schizophrène ne
veut pas m'appeler janus a très très
clairement mais c'est pas ça comme
positions à la vente aujourd'hui alors
oui je dis non c'est pas ben ben là
c'est que ça met un comptable de ce
bilan de nicolas sarkozy j'ai appelé à
voter nicolas sarkozy entre les deux
tours élection présidentielle je ne le
regrette pas parce que je voulais
engager la transformation d'un pays qui
depuis 25 ans décline mais pour vous
cette union alors cédé en 2007 et le
même journal est toujours valable
tu as laissé mourir mais en même temps
aujourd'hui je porte un projet qui doit
être un projet alternatif parce que il y
a le fonctionnement du pouvoir
la démocratie telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui en france ne me convient pas
je veux un système plus équilibré
je veux une démocratie dans laquelle la
diversité de la société française puisse
s'exprimer
et où je crois profondément que le
collectif permet l'expression de la
meilleure écoute solution alors je
prends des exemples attendait l'exemple
mais en filigrane c'est la critique de
gouvernance de sarkozy ce que
vous ne prenez jamais cru en l'homme
providentiel d'ailleurs les centristes
naturellement vol une démocratie qui
souhaitent une démocratie dans lesquels
il y ait des pouvoirs et des
contre-pouvoirs nous pas pour empêcher
le pouvoir mais au contraire pour
permettre au pouvoir d'être en capacité
de convaincre l'opinion publique parce
qu'il a construit formaté convaincu sa
propre majorité
je prends un exemple parce que c'est
mieux de prendre exemple prenons un
exemple vous avez aujourd'hui à l'heure
où je vous parle
un débat à l'assemblée nationale qui
s'appelle le débat sur la règle d'or
c'est à dire l'interdiction des
déséquilibres des déficits de
fonctionnement
la france vit en situation de déficit
budgétaire
depuis trente ans nous sommes passés de
300 milliards d'euros de déficit
budgétaire dernier budget en équilibre
raymond barre un centriste à 1800
milliards
la totalité de l'impôt sur le revenu ne
suffit pas pour payer les intérêts de la
dette
la france est dans une situation
budgétaire et d'endettement qui
l'amènera à être confrontés aux mêmes
réalités que la grèce dans quelques
années si elle ne répond pas à cet
engagement
nous avons donc dit non pas seulement
parce qu'il faut s'occuper ne pas porter
sur les générations futures la charge de
la dette mais aussi pour une question de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
parce que quand votre endettement
devient massif ce sont les marchés ce
sont les autres qui décident de votre
politique
nous avons dit pour faciliter la vertu
il nous faut introduire cette obligation
constitutionnelle de présenter un budget
en équilibre
en 2008 j'ai encore le souvenir d'un
président de la république en face de
moi avec mes collègues du nouveau centre
visant cette règle là c'est très bien
mais c'est d'abord une question de
volonté politique et pas besoin de
règles
je constate que trois ans plus tard le
même président de la république trouve
que c'est tellement bien qu'il le fait
inscrire à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale eh bien si nous
avions eu
un gouvernement de coalition dans la
dentelle
le une expression lui d' écoute une
expression différente voulant participer
à la construction utt éclaté nous nous
serions peut-être pas là allergies on va
voir si votre parole se libère plus
avant avec pierre heures
luccioni de la fp qui va nous rejoindre
un mot avant de voir un petit peu où en
est votre ambition pour le centre un mot
quand même sur la mort d'un grand sens
triste on a appris aujourd'hui le décès
de bernard stasi
voilà l'exemple d'un centriste qui était
habité par de fortes convictions
quels souvenirs examen le juge un homme
de coeur de respect de l'individu de
tolérance de respect de la diversité et
de la différence d'expression est un
immense européen voilà un européen
fédéral comme nous voulons lettre très
bien alors hervé morin comme nicolas
sarkozy j'ai vu un même point commun
vont multiplier les déplacements en ce
moment j'avais je fais un tour de france
vous êtes un podium demain vous prenez
beaucoup de machines dans la manche sur
la marche
ah oui c'est ça dans la mort de l'âme
demain je vais voir j'ai une journée
consacrée
d'une part à la production laitière et
après à l'ostréiculture voilà avec donc
ce livre à paraître on vous dénoncer le
mépris dont les françaises sont l'objet
selon vous thomas raguet universités
d'été du nouveau centre en août dernier
hervé morin alors toujours au
gouvernement joue collectif mais se
permet quelques crocs en jambe
sur la politique sécuritaire du
gouvernement notamment lien temps nous
devons exercer notre liberté de parole
une critique plutôt sobre mais un
premier signe d'émancipation pour le
président du nouveau centre
deux mois plus tard il est débarqué du
gouvernement
sa parole se fait alors plus libre j'ai
vu apparaître une équipe de campagne ump
proche du rpr hervé morin se verrait
bien incarner seul ce centre mais jean
louis borloo de son côté passe à
l'offensive en quittant l'ump l'a
évidemment vocation à avoir un candidat
à cette élection là hervé morin
désormais émancipé défi le chef de
l'état
dans son nouveau livre ses critiques se
font plus aiguisée mais pour ses anciens
amis du modem hervé morin est dans
l'impasse
on peut pas être à ce point avoir été à
ce point dans le système à voir à ce
point aider le président de la
république est à ce point sont détachés
d'ailleurs c'est une certaine façon pas
très correct vis-à-vis de la majorité et
vis-à-vis du président de la république
je pense que les gens ils ont besoin
aussi d'un certain nombre de fidélité
aux idées et aux gens qui les portent et
donc ça il reconnaît transfert
semble-t-il
quant aux centristes de l'ump il digère
mal son revirement des derniers mois je
pense pas que les centristes vont gagner
vont faire gagner leurs idées avec des
arêtes vives et des petites phrases
je crois d'ailleurs que jean louis
borloo l'a très bien compris lui parce
qu'il essaie de se positionner sur des
sujets de fond
à force d'émancipation hervé morin est
désormais libre de parole et de
mouvement tellement libre qu'il en
paraîtrait presque seul voilà avec
pierre roché ciolino que maintenant de
la fp qui nous a rejoint
hervé morin bonjour voire même alors en
2007 vous avez quitté françois bayrou
pour mort a quitté françois bayrou je
refuse cela non non non non non vous
avez apporté en tout cas notre soutien à
nicolas sarkozy non on peut dire c'est
avons nous avons une charrue piccioli
nous avons même déjeuné ensemble ce midi
je vous ai raconté précisément les
choses qui sont d'ailleurs dans le livre
qui paraîtra chez toujours dire françois
bayrou je me souviendrai news et là ça
frise les roues qui vous ait quitté
j'ai toujours dit à françois bayrou je
soutiendrai et nicolas sarkozy parce que
les valeurs que je défends ne m'amène
pas à un accord avec le parti socialiste
et avec ses camarades de gauche et donc
quand françois bayrou qui je vous le
rappelle a été sur l'intérêt général de
valéry giscard d'estaing membres
d'edouard balladur président du df
décide de ne pas appeler de appelle les
français à ne pas voter nicolas sarkozy
rappellent ils
c'est lui qui abandonne sa famille
politique permettez moi de vous inviter
à lire un sondage qui va paraître dans
48 heures à la question qui a été posée
sur notamment aux français est ce que le
centre une doit être est naturellement
associé un parti de droite et un parti
de gauche
je ne dévoile pas son âge mais quand
vous aurez les résultats vous verrez à
quel point ma position n'est pas
simplement celle d'un sondage mais elle
a été aussi celle des français je vous
rappelle que 70% des français qui ont
voté françois bayrou au premier tour ont
fait le même choix que moi donc s'il
vous plaît
le côté il y a ceux qu'ont quitté bayrou
merci d'accord alors vous n'avez pas
quitté françois bayrou mais vous avez
quand même appelé à voter nicolas
sarkozy au premier tour
au premier tour on est on soutient un
candidat pour un projet et au second
tour refait on se rallie à la ou alors
les environs parce que vous l'avez dit
des colas sarkozy ne s'était pas
prononcée était contre le principe d'un
parti unique vous l'avez vous l'avez dit
et quand vous avez quitté le
gouvernement vous avez on l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure dénoncer l'arrivée d'un
état rpr est ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir été floués par le
candidat sarkozy par les promesses du
candidat sarkozy
moi j'ai le souvenir ce que m'a dit le
président de la république il y avait
tous les parlementaires du nouveau
centre autour de moi ce jour là il nous
a dit je toujours été contre le parti
unique
j'ai toujours pensé que la majorité se
porterait mieux si elle est tête s'il y
avait au moins deux parties notamment
une expression centriste
qu'est-ce qu'il nous a demandé il nous a
dit voilà c'est un contrat et c'est un
contrat de majorité ce contrat de
majorité sauf bouleversement politique
majeur qui fait que vous décidez de le
rompre ce contrat de majorité
il repose sur deux choses simples vote
du budget le vote de la loi de finances
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et bien sûr la motion sanctions
à la question de confiance sur le reste
soyez vous même moi ce que je regrette
sincèrement c'est que la faiblesse
l'absence notre notre force insuffisante
nous est empêché de pouvoir exprimer et
de peser assez sur les choix et les
arbitrages de la majorité donc si je
suis fier d'avoir participé à un
gouvernement qui a enfin réalisé une
réforme qui restera historique
l'autonomie des universités bravo tous
les gouvernements de droite et de gauche
le voulait l'ancien universitaire que je
suis l'espérait tout ça fait que sur ce
sujet là comme sur bien d'autres jeux je
suis fier ça et en même temps lui un
certain nombre d'erreurs de fautes et
des déceptions sur un certain nombre de
sujets voilà oui mais vous dites la
république exemplaire pas que ces
noms-là sarkozy au nom un exemple si un
exemple simple est ce que la république
a été exemplaire
comme nous le souhaitions je ne crois
pas alors justement sur ce point vous
avez vous avez dit en quittant le
gouvernement que vous étiez heureux
d'avoir retrouvé votre liberté de cinq
ans vous avez alors l'occasion de
l'exercer on n'est pas dans une espèce
de la provocation déception vous dites
la façon dont la france est gouvernée la
couette
je pense que les gens vont savoir que
dans votre livre vous fait un lien avec
la personnalité du chef de l'état qu'est
ce que j'ai envie de dire j'ai surgi au
de gouvernance de nicolas sarkozy quel
bilan vous tirez sur ces quatre ans
écoutez vous voyez je vais vous j'ai
fait un mea culpa
j'étais de ceux qu'il considérait qu'il
fallait supprimer la fonction de premier
ministre alors qu'on avait un
quinquennat qui
était accompagné des élections
législatives qui avait lieu dans la
foulée
je pense que c'est une erreur je pense
qu'on a besoin d'un vrai premier
ministre qui soit celui qui conduit la
politique de la nation au quotidien
qu'on a besoin d'un programme public qui
prennent de la hauteur qui donne un sens
je pense que sur ce sujet là on n'a pas
voilà que sur ce sujet là on est en
présence d'un public était premier
ministre en même temps c'est pas de
faire de notre fillon non bah après
probablement qu'il ya des rapports de
force que vous êtes capable de
construire ou non
je pense que le les arbitrages rendus
par le présent un public sur des sujets
relevant de l'interministériel ou du
premier ministre empêche probablement de
pouvoir construire une démocratie dans
laquelle les français d'une part
constate l'action quotidienne à travers
un premier ministre et par un peu plus
de rareté dans la parole obtiennent du
président un public le sens de l'action
menée par le chef de l'état pour
transformer le pays on va revenir un
type sur l'actualité hier soir vous avez
rencontré vos amis centristes jean louis
borloo jean marie bockel je vais pas
tous les citer bons qui sont pas jean
marie bockel
enfin ceux qui sont partenaires de la
future confédération centriste vous vous
êtes mis d'accord sur le principe de
valeur et sur les statuts du sida future
confédération
en ce qui concerne les valeurs qu est ce
qui vous différencie aujourd'hui de
l'ump bah écoutez on vient d'évoquer des
sujets je la question de la gouvernance
du comportement pouvoir de ce que
j'appelle pour moi la sobriété du
pouvoir je pense que les français ne
veulent pas un état modeste mais ils
veulent un état sobre sobre dans la
dépense sobre dans l'exercice quotidien
du pouvoir sobre avec ce qu'il faut de
hauteur mais ce qu'il faut aussi de
proximité je pense que sur ce sujet là
il ya une vraie distinction avec
nos partenaires de l'ump je prends un
deuxième sujet je pense que nous avons
porté longuement un sujet une réforme de
la fiscalité en profondeur pour
améliorer le pouvoir d'achat des
français
je suis favorable à la tva sociale pour
détaxer massivement les cotisations
sociales et pour permettre aux
entreprises de mieux payer les salariés
et pour faire en sorte que tous les
produits importés au moment des actes de
moment de l'acte de consommation
financent une partie de notre protection
sociale
nous sommes nous troisième sujet par
exemple profondément favorable à la
construction d'une europe fédérale
on va vers plus d'intégration politique
plus d'intégration fiscale plus
d'intégration sociale je suis pas
certain que ça puisse se faire à 27 je
pense que ça peut ça doit se faire c'est
pas le cas du ep coûté jamais entendu le
mp nous dire qu'il était qu'elle était
favorable à l'europe fédérale et je ne
crois pas que l'exercice du pouvoir tel
qu'il a été pendant cinq ans démontre
que le président publique est favorable
à une construction fédéral très bien en
ce qui concerne les statuts vous avez
ouvert la possibilité à des membres
associés de participer à la
confédération c'est à dire à des
personnes qui pourraient éventuellement
être des centristes qui concerne le qui
conservent leur étiquette ump
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que ça
brouille un petit peu les cartes pour
l'opinion publique
sachant que vous revendiquez d'être un
parti autonome l'opinion publique
vous savez la politique c'est d'abord
une incarnation d'opinion publique verra
les hommes et les femmes engagées dans
un processus de proposition d'une
alternative
en même temps nous avons voulu être
ouvert et ouvrir les fenêtres les portes
les persiennes les volets faire en sorte
que toutes celles et tous ceux qui se
considèrent comme des centristes
puissent participer à nos travaux et
venir progressivement
rejoindre notre démarche c'est ça que
nous avons lu fait sûr de ça ce bruit
c'est pour reprendre une image on m
comme moi qui suis normand la manche
n'est pas toujours très chaude souvent
on commence par mettre le pied avant de
se dire on va plonger ou non bien voilà
permettre de goûter la mer en quelque
sorte avant de décider de plongée alors
samedi c'est le grand rendez vous pour
les les nouveaux centres vous allez
présenter au conseil national de votre
parti c'est le parlement du parti en
quelque sorte la proposition bien les
institutions de nouveau la possibilité
enfin la possibilité d'intégrer cette
confédération quel est le message que
vous aller délivrer à vos militants
moi mon message est simple le nouveau
centre doit être l'ossature du
rassemblement car nous avons deux mines
élus locaux dix sept mille militants
imparti à peu près constitué dans tous
les départements à une quinzaine près et
donc rien ne peut se faire sans notre
engagement complet et total nous sommes
ceux avec lesquels la maison peut se
construire et donc je veux que nous
soyons complètement engagé dans
rassemblement que le candidat en 2012
doit sortir de goran et le candidat de
2012 sortira de notre de notre analyse
de celui qui notre analyse commune j'ai
pas demain ne recentre notre analyse
commune à l'automne 2011 où vous devez
renoncer à régénérer renoncé à rien et
ma deuxième le deuxième message que je
voudrais que je ferais pas c'est qu'un
quelque sorte le contrat de notre
engagement
c'est dans ce dans cette confédération
c'est un devoir et une exigence de
candidature c'est pas une obligation
c'est une exigence de candidature à
l'égard de toutes celles et tous ceux
qui se reconnaissent dans notre courant
de pensée et dans nos valeurs alors si
jean louis borloo à la pole-position
pause pole position par d'aujourd'hui
vous êtes toujours
la course en fait à moi je suis
complètement dans la course je n'ai
jamais abandonné
vous qui pensait ça c'est parce que la
question j'ai vos services et que vous
êtes moins imprévisible que lui je suis
totalement déterminé
moi j'ai vous savez j'ai j'ai ce même si
monsieur rqic limon a fait la critique
tout à l'heure j'ai un immense avantage
c'est que j'ai fait deux campagnes avec
un homme qui était crédité d'un demi
pour cent dans les sondages à trois
semaines du premier tour c'était en 2002
et d'un homme dont la plupart des
observateurs politiques disait qu'en
2007 que s'il faisait 5 % ce serait déjà
merveilleux
donc moi j'ai pas peur j'ai jamais eu
peur j'ai toujours considéré que la
politique ça devait être un engagement
c'est pas ça n'est pas non plus
l'isolément pour répondre anciens
camarades du modem c'est pas une
démarche solitaire et c'est pour ça que
je suis je veux jouer collectif et que
je ne veux pas que nous soyons dans
l'opposition plein à l'autre entre
borloo et jean louis et moi du qu'une
des principales qualités pour un
candidat à la présidentielle c'était la
détermination la volonté la volonté
royer je pense que je vous disais ce
midi c'est que pourquoi françois
hollande apparaît aujourd'hui comme un
outsider capable de gagner la primaire
au sein du parti socialiste
c'est parce que lui démontre une
détermination et une volonté absolue et
une détermination et une détermination
tel qu'il en est même capable de faire
un immense et ford à 16 bon sang vous
avez presque plus envie d'y aller que
jean-louis borloo ne s'est pas posé la
question jean louis borloo mais moi j'ai
le sentiment qu'il a aussi envie d'y
aller parler donc avec lui on se parle
très simplement
on a décidé d sur une relation de
confiance et n'attendez pas de moi
la demie fera ce qui pourrait nous
amener à à vous donner le sentiment
qu'on est dans une concurrence stérile
je suis déterminé il en a aussi en vie
et bien nous non mais je vous sentez
plus déterminé que lui n'en je dis
simplement ce que je suis un peu mis à
mal évolué devrait vous rendiez tous les
ans nous aurons nous aurons un rendez
vous que nous organiserons ensemble très
bien merci merci on va accueillir
maintenant perrine tarneaud on va
d'abord revenir sur bas sur vos atouts à
hervé morin oui oui si vous commencez
par les attaques après où sont leurs
autres retards aussi voilà j'y arrive
puisque nous parlons du sondage des
sondages vous concernant tout cela est
évoqué par 30 à nuit 1% d'intentions de
vote pour la présidentielle c'est le
maigre score dont hervé morin est
crédité par les instituts de sondage la
faute certainement un déficit de
notoriété
alors le président du nouveau centre met
les bouchées doubles ses premières armes
il l'a dévoilé pour la nouvelle année
mes chers amis je suis heureux de vous
souhaiter la bonne année chez moi et
probablement dans le lieu que j'aime le
plus dans mon appartement c'est à dire
ma cuisine
et oui le 2 sur internet le principe est
simple tout est permis pourvu qu'on
parle de soi même si les internautes
sont plus préoccupés par la mise en
scène entre casserole est insolente et
père noël sur le plan de travail et ça
marche
33 mille vidéos visionnées contre
seulement 2500 pour le cru précédent
mais ne vous y méprenez pas hervé morin
veut aussi prouver qu'il a du fond et du
métier loin de certains lapsus qui l'a
laissée au ministère de la défense parce
que c'est difficile d'expliquer à des
cons raid à ddd hommes et des femmes lui
qui a mis deux mois à prendre le
garde-à-vous part et c'est peut-être un
peu nonchalant aux yeux de la raideur
militaire mais aujourd'hui le hervé
morin nouveau est arrivé
c'est un bosseur fou répète on dans son
entourage entre les étapes de son tour
de france à la rencontre des
préoccupations des citoyens
il porta serait paraît-il jour et nuit
faire des coups être dans le fond le
dosage n'est pas toujours évident c'est
en tout cas la recette d'hervé morin
pour faire prendre la mayonnaise d'une
éventuelle candidature est une démarche
d'indépendance
voilà alors tout le monde va regarder
cette vidéo s'est moqué aussi avec moi
vous l'aviez encore pas vu la cuisine la
variable à vous savez en fait ce sont
les voeux aux militants
chaque année c'est une espèce de
l'exercice d'exercice reid exercice
imposé
et puis comme je venais d'enregistrer
une émission sur cuisine tv puisque
j'aime faire la cuisine et on a eu cette
idée voilà et donc ça a été un peu
improvisé à 23 décembre soir bon voilà
alors en effet les cuisines mais mais
mais mais j'ajoute que le père noël
c'est le père noël de mon petit garçon
quelques mois auparavant quand vous
étiez à la défense ça n'a pas été un
long fleuve tranquille
aubin c'est une magnifique
responsabilité c'est aussi une épreuve
physique
voilà pas mal de critiques jade et votre
nomination peut-être qu'on vous trouvez
que vous n'aviez pas la tête de l'emploi
trop souri entre décontracté on a revu
les images de la passation de pouvoirs
avec michèle alliot marie elle marche de
façon très solennelle très raide
bah oui oui j'ai du mal à vous m ji min
de jeu
démarche que certains qualifient de
marge cowboys
il sera chez d'isoler cela changerait
pas
bon on a mis deux mois non non c'est pas
ça le mandat s'achève à le faire de moi
à prendre le garde à vous oui j'ai pas
j'ai pas mis deux mois à prendre géant
jusqu'au jour on m'a dit qu'il y avait
quelques éléments à corriger
bon c'est pas tout ça n'est pas
dramatique je pense que en trois ans et
demi j'ai fait beaucoup de choses au
sein du ministère
j'ai engagé une réforme qu'on disait
impossible la réforme de la carte
militaire tout le monde me disait ça
sera une jacquerie absolue tous les élus
seront dehors et cetera
on en a parlé 24 heures je vois qu'on en
a beaucoup moins parlé que de la
fermeture d'un tribunal d'instance avec
cinq personnes non mais une base
aérienne de 2000 personnes c'est ses 60
à 80 millions d'euros sur un bassin
local c'est un autre sujet mais j'ai
fait j'ai apporté la preuve au titre de
la réforme de l'état que par la
concertation le dialogue et la
responsabilité
on pouvait transformer et changer
quelque chose qui semble est impossible
je les fais pendant des mois à discuter
à regarder à convaincre chaque élu
chaque député chaque sénateur chaque
maire et finalement on fait une réforme
qui nous permettra de réaliser 1
milliard 600 millions d'euros
d'économies de fonctionnement pour les
armes est réinvesti dans dans
l'équipement alors finalement peut-être
qui a été le plus dur à gérer quand vous
étiez visiteurs de la défense et les
relations entre le chef de l'état et les
militaires
non je vous écoute et moi j'ai géré j'ai
fait mon boulot je me suis pas posé ces
questions là moi j'ai pas on pense par
exemple aux propos du de nicolas sarkozy
au moment de la fusillade
à carcassonne où il avait traité les
militaires d'amateurs il ya quand même
eu des des petites bisbilles
oui mais tout ça et tout ça a été un
procès c'est pas très bien entre le chef
de sa reynard je me tiens tout ça a été
un procès d'intention je raconte dans
mon livre vous verrez d'accord on va
attendre de cliffs et sa non alors vous
nous renvoyez avoir à votre livre
toujours il paraît que vous vous appuyez
sur la personnalité de nicolas sarkozy
pour critiquer sa gouvernance je vous en
dirai moi je vais je
je vous laisse le soin d'y apporter et
de le lire ce que j'ai voulu faire à
travers cet ouvrage c'est d'abord et
avant tout deux à la fois de mon
expérience gouvernementale au coeur du
pouvoir pendant trois années et demie
est par ce tour de france que j'ai
engagé de porter un de porter un projet
politique de dire voilà mon expérience
politique
voilà ce que j'entends en france
voilà les témoignages voilà les
expériences voilà les innovations qui
existe dans notre pays et à partir de
cela qu est ce qu on peut penser que je
prends un exemple j'ai travaillé
beaucoup sur les questions d'éducation
est ce qu'on peut continuer à être dans
un pays où 20% des jeunes sortent de cm2
en situation d'illettrisme et 20% dont
le niveau scolaire est extrêmement
préoccupant c'est à dire que sur une
classe d'âge vous avez 40 % qui sont sur
le risque de l'exclusion du chômage
voire pour certains nombre de deux le
constat tout le monde le fait je
constate tout le monde le fait mais
j'apporte des solutions j'apporte des
solutions notamment à travers ce que
j'ai pu constater c'est que vous ne
pouvez pas avoir un projet pédagogique
unique pour toute la france
quand vous avez d'un côté des enfants
issus de milieux favorisés avec un
niveau socioculturel élevés et de
l'autre des enfants issus d'une zone
urbaine sensible dont les parents ne
connaissent ni ne connaissent ni ne
lisent le français est donc moi je dis
il faut un sur l'exemple des universités
un statut d'autonomie des établissements
scolaires avec pour chaque établissement
scolaire un contrat avec
l'administration qui lui donne des
moyens pour pouvoir mener son projet
pédagogique en fonction de la population
scolaire et de recruter cet enseignant
de façon autonome en fonction du profil
de faire atterrir un peu sur
l'expérimentation
l'expérimentation qui sont monnaies
diverses et variées qui souvent ne reste
que des expérimentations mettez sur
plein de dossiers de fond la volonté
c'est de montrer que vous avez une
crédibilité l'habit d'un présidentiable
on a bien compliqué il faut avoir une
nuit sur un sujet comme maintenant sur
ce tour de france vous inspire un petit
peu aussi la campagne de françois bayrou
en 2007 qui était parti comme ça très en
amont en visite en région par région et
en exploitant tous ces thèmes
je ne cherche pas à faire l'exemple de
françois bayrou pourriez prendre jacques
chirac vous pourriez apprendre beaucoup
d'autres pourquoi je veux porter l'idée
d'une société de la reconnaissance c'est
le le thème que je souhaite développer
parce que je j'entends tous les jours
des français qui ont le sentiment de ne
pas être respectés ni reconnus qui ont
le sentiment qu'on ne leur accorde pas
la reconnaissance qui devrait être la
leur en fonction de ce qu'ils apportent
à la société française
alors c'est bien entendu la question du
pouvoir d'achat quand vous allez je vais
vous donner un exemple concret c'est ça
qui est passionnant c'est absolument
passionnant sur de france quand vous
allez dans une endive riz sais pas si
vous avez déjà été dans un livre et je
ne pense pas que vous sachiez comment
supplétives l'endive moi non plus je ne
savais pas tout en ayant des racines
paysannes qu'une que des femmes qui ont
25 ans de boulot qui ont bien entendu
des problèmes articulaires et
musculaires liées à la répétition des
gestes que ces femmes avec lesquelles
vous prenez un verre vous dire monsieur
j'avais une bonne tête m sympathique
mais qu'est ce que vous pouvez pour moi
je travaille depuis 25 ans et je gagne
on 100 euros par mois et c'est un
scandale
et ils ont raison c'est un scandale qui
va les aider pour le sujet le sujet
c'est comment on fait pour améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat et j'ai voté
l'exonération des cotisations sociable
fermeture la ville
l'asile coûter moins cher j'ai en
belgique de gendt qui a défendu je
prends un autre exemple de ce que pour
moi peut représenter une société de la
reconnaissance
avant-hier soir j'étais dans un service
d'urgences de l'ap-hp deux hôpitaux de
paris à l'hôtel dieu précisément la
reconnaissance pour une aide soignante
passionné par son métier ou pour un
infirmier qui a choisi ce métier en
sachant que toute façon on va pas gagner
des milles et des cents mais que 1
on lui donne la possibilité de la
promotion sociale c'est-à-dire de
financer un parcours professionnel
l'aide soignante qui a d'abord été agent
de service qui est devenue aide
soignante de pouvoir être inférieur à
financer ces parcours
deuxième exemple que la le la salle de
garde c'est à dire là où on passe ses
nuits et ses bien qu'à peinture soit à
peu près correct que la douche ne soit
pas rempli de moisi qu' il n'y ait pas
un seul lit pour 4 personnes c'est aussi
ça la reconnaissance de nos compatriotes
comment est ce que vous qualifiez
aujourd'hui vos relations avec nicolas
sarkozy
elles sont bonnes et on ne se parle pas
après la publication de votre livre vous
ne vous parlerais plus jamais écouté et
du tout quelques temps écoutez vous
savez j'ai le souvenir d'un certain
nombre de membres du gouvernement ayant
eu des propos assez terrible surprise
dans la république et kike dans les
semaines après rentrer au gouvernement
il ne vous souvenez vous de ce qu'a pu
dire thierry mariani par exemple tout
cela mais quel est le plus grand défaut
puisque vous dites qu'il est brutale
outrée indécent et que sa gouvernance
avant cela n'en fait pas dans votre
dictionnaire en eau qui reviennent sais
pas si ça c'est du résumé
ce sont des mots non parce que ça c'est
si vous prenez un bout de phrase et que
à portée de sa valeur intègre le défaut
alors que vous lui reprochez en priorité
que vous lui adressez pardon le
sentiment que quand on fait les choses
que comme on vous le dira le sentiment
que il faut s'occuper de tout et que il
ya que lui qui fait bien d'accord merci
hervé maurey merci péri la semaine
prochaine laurent fabius sera notre
invité ben serait un autre normand voilà
un autre mur mans